Sống như sẽ có chết
Mình cũng không biết là làm mình sẽ chết khi nào nữa
Mình có khi mình đi ngoài đuần cửa như mình bị tay nạn như sao
Thì cái thiếu mà mình bị bắt nó cũng chỉ là một cái cái nhé kéo là
Nó plơ là bởi vì nó rất là bởi vì nó nhiều như mà mình
Mình sẽ tìm bị uống thu là hạn nó hạn
Đó với mình yêu đấy mình cái chết rất là nghe
Nà như năng lành tục phăng tục tăng ở bên anh gà đi học, mình thấy tự nhiên là đúng ra trong năm dưới
Một cái bệnh điện sông năm dưới, một cái dưới bật không là nó chết
Nó rất là chán
Thế còn bây giờ mình đi làm
Anh được qua vào, đẩy mình đi đỡ mắt về tốt phạm
Đồ trắng mai như ở mà trắng mai có chuyện gì sẽ là
Thà bị xúc bán
Con hơn là nắng chết thân lại người bật
Nếu như là mặt sợ chết
Thì bạn mới sợ như cái này
Con như như với tờ bạn còn chết mặt chả sợ
Đối bạn nói là một cái chuyện gì như nó sẽ giảm một cái lúc nào đẹn
Nó sẽ giảm sợi nó thôi
Bặt sợng trong những cái cách là
Vì bây giờ tôi làm một cái điều gì để giá giãi giãi với khúc sống của tôi
Đi quên, đúc xem thế này
Bây giờ sẽ có bộ bộ khá sợp 1st step
Mới nhất